i want to take an email that we got and
it caused some discussion here
in the office and um so here's the
here's the email it's from shay
shay writes i recently got out of an
abusive relationship and my ex
is now dating someone new i approached
her and told her
about his abuse sex addiction and
cheating
so shay approached the new girlfriend
and said hey
um i'm gonna tell you about his abuse
sex addiction and cheating
she says she hasn't experienced these
issues and is staying with him
should i do more to try and convince her
or is there a possibility that their
relationship
could actually be healthy
so when i read this my first thought was
what are you doing
don't go to your ex-boyfriend's new
girlfriend and start running him down
except the thing she was running him
down was about abuse
and also his infidelity and sex
addiction
so my first thought was
yeah i guess their relationship could be
healthy
if he actually was an abusive person
whether and it doesn't say what kind of
abuse so let's say emotional abuse and
he was a sex addict and he was a cheater
yeah those are probably gonna show up
again those behaviors unless he just saw
the light one day walking down the road
and um so i guess they could be healthy
my bigger challenge is this you don't
get a vote
it's not your relationship shay you
don't get to speak into
your ex's new relationship with somebody
else
and i know that's so hard to hear
but you shouldn't be calling her right
she says she hasn't experienced these
things that she knows of
that's not your that's not your
responsibility you got to go quietly
into the night
and go find somebody else what do y'all
think
so if it if it is a like actual
i mean abuse is abuse but say it's
physical abuse and it's something pretty
serious yeah
and you know that and they're they're
dating somebody new
like what what responsibility do you
have if any like
you just kind of sit back and so if
somebody was
physically unsafe right i would call the
police
and let them get involved in that and
say hey i was harmed by this person this
person is now with somebody else and
the police would do a welfare check and
go check in on that person
i can't i can't wrap my head around
calling an ex's
new person and being like hey just so
you know does that make sense
i mean if they're like in the maybe
they're in the same friend circle or
something like that yeah
it wouldn't yeah maybe that's it maybe
maybe she's friends with
the other person too as a female i would
say if
i had dated a guy especially if we're
talking physical abuse
physical abuse feels different yeah it
feels different
and he had physically abused someone
previously
i would want to know that either through
the ex calling me or if we had a mutual
friend that we could call
because my thought reality the police
aren't going to do anything nothing's
happened
they don't have time so i would want to
know that because i would
that's information i would need to know
before i decided to stay
if the if there's possible physical
abuse
what about hey he's a cheater
sounds like i wonder if she cheated with
him like on you
if how would that call go hey i want you
to know that this guy cheats and she
would be like yeah i super know because
i was the other person well i took that
i did the email so i know that that was
there was overlap between the two of
them oh okay and she did let her know
that but she made the choice to stay but
i wouldn't think
that you would necessarily need to call
on that but but when it's physical
safety
and it could be somebody's life yeah so
yes you took that to deathcon that she
ended the email by saying
or is there a chance it could work it
sounds like she's just trying to get in
the in their business
that's when i read it i felt like hey i
just need to let her know that he's not
very nice don't say
sorry your relationship with him is over
he's an ex right
now this whole thing gets messier if
they've got kids together or there's
some other
you know they share a house together or
something like that i think we took one
of those calls once where
we broke up but we're still sharing a
house but
yeah i do agree if there is a chance
that somebody's not safe you got to let
somebody know
right you got to make that phone call
but at the end of the day if you break
up
you broke up right and someone has
addictions or cheating
i'm gonna say stay out of it and keep
your relationship
go get with your yeah
i don't know man i really wish i was
talking to shea in person here because i
have a thousand different questions here
but yeah mind your business i wish i had
another nicer way to say that mind your
business
sound good mind your business yeah
that's the kind of great uh radio
coaching i get from the producer i think
this is why we don't do email questions
a ton because
it requires a lot of digging in so yeah
there you go
well way to beat funrunner.com.net.org
james childs
i happen to love this uh email question
shae thank you for writing in
if you have any more email questions
write to johndeloney.com
show do not put the www in front of all
that because you don't even have to
because it's
2021 go to john delany.com show kelly
will pick it up and if it's a great
email
and she can somehow get it through james
then we'll do another email on the show
so so glad you wrote shay that's a messy
one man
yeah mind your business